the Joe Rogan experience they don't have
killer whale shows there anymore well
that killed that particular killer whale
kiss cos she's the only one left in
Canada there's no more in Canada's not
ever going to be marine lands never
gonna get another one
she's been sort of unresponsive for a
long time she's on a lot of medication
medication Oh tons of Medicaid what kind
of medication you put a killer whale on
well she's got different I mean you
could gauge the blood you start putting
on my antibiotics antibiotic you get
them on how do you take blood from a
killer whale flip them over and they got
out they've got a in their tail there's
a series of large veins you just roll
them over they let you yeah everything
is everything is everything is trained
in that there you're gonna provide it
voluntarily
so and it takes a long time to train
these things but you train them sit and
you just prick it you just literally
grab this little needle you put it in
the in the vein they don't get pissed at
you they get pissed if you miss and you
keep trying oh don't do that
[ __ ] yeah I've seen it happens but they
let you take their blood if they're
healthy and responsive yeah of course if
they're not there's nothing that's gonna
get you to the get them to the edge of
the pool but so you you take their blood
and then they what do they find
is it allowed you want to look at
cortisol levels how the stress is you
want to look at white blood count see if
they're fighting any infections you know
there's always you know in her case
there's always something a lot of the
animals are in fact on valium a lot of
different sites yeah tons what that that
is like rampant use in in in the
equipment aquariums y-yeah valium yeah
I'm reelin accused me of stealing valium
and in fact in the lawsuit as well which
is absolutely not true is this is this
used everywhere oh yeah just Greenland
oh not just marine land sea world's
everywhere yeah what yes like dolphins
dolphins are on valium all the time sure
I when I was when I was when I left
marine land I had the agreement again I
left fairly amicably considering the the
the situation but you know I wanted to
play my cards right and marine lands
owner called me back in specifically to
help a dolphin and it was defeated of
course though I wish that was in the
Daily Mail what's what's the other one
the dodo is the dodo a good one buzz for
you let's go with BuzzFeed SeaWorld puts
its whales on valent volume like drug
documents say Jesus [ __ ] those documents
are from Allah
suit between marine land and sea world
where SeaWorld sued marine land sea on
Terror at SeaWorld sued marina they're
all benzodiazepines I'm telling you Wow
trainers give their orcas on the awesome
scale killer whales a psychoactive drug
benzodiazepine according to the sworn
affidavit filed an hour to Ontario
Superior Court of Justice and dispute
between the park company and a rival
company
Marineland over the transport of a
prized killer whale Eike Eike Eike Eike
Eike is if you watch blackfish you've
got Tilikum that's the one that killed
ya that's people that's Tilikum son we
had his son Wow we had him he was I mean
he captivity right in captivity in a
pool by himself or the most raised in
Cabot bred and born in captivity yeah
and he was turning aggressive and
SeaWorld was like they were having none
of it they wanted that killer whale back
and I don't blame him it's amazing I'm
sued for millions because I'm alleging
that that marine land is mistreating
their animals
SeaWorld Sue's marine land because
they're mistreating they're not up
taking appropriate care of the killer
whale and actually win the lawsuit they
would not put any barriers around the
pool we've got a marina had a large pool
imagine this unimpeded ability to touch
a killer whale if you wanted to reach
it's not a safe idea this is absurd in
fact that's which when you're dealing
with a large you know boisterous male
Orca so SeaWorld wanted barriers around
it so that people can't get close well
the owner Marineland you can't tell him
what to do he's not gonna do nothing
anyone tells him what to do so suddenly
we're dealing with the fact that this
animal started to lunge at the public
now this is an animal that if it gets
ahold of someone it's over there's gonna
tie with them for a bit we're gonna hear
a lot of screaming but the screaming
will end you're not getting anyone out
of that killer whales month forget it
and this is what SeaWorld was dealing
with they're just like [ __ ] dad enough
bad press even back then if I kick it
kill someone or hurt someone or anything
or dies in marine lands care it's gonna
look bad and see what so see was like
getting the [ __ ] out now when tilikum
killed people you get killed how many
people one person is granted uh three to
four actually in Victoria Canada the
first one then he went to I think it's
absolutely hilarious they kept training
them and kept doing things what does a
pit bull forget about it be done but
it's a killer well almost any M
Maddi they are a lion they were training
you know lions and the lion killed
someone they like that's a wrap
unless that watch that's not truly was
that one grizzly bear that was a trained
grizzly bear for films it was in what's
that movie something forty some football
movie with a big bear anyway
the bear killed the guy's brother or
cousin the guy was just standing there
it's a horrible video you could watch
the video I've seen it the guy just
standing there and the bear just decides
to tear the guys throat apart just
reaches up bites him rips his throat
open the guy runs off grabbed his neck
he's dead within minutes the joys of
working with animals man I mean without
bear they kept alive and they started
training him again and there's some
really weird footage of the guy training
the bear again it was the one from the
Will Ferrell movie semi-pro yes
semi-pro that's the dog or the dog
that's the bear that bear [ __ ] killed
somebody look this guy's smacking this
bear around look at will that bear
eventually killed somebody I just got
tired of people it takes nothing for him
oh it's so easy for him yeah just
decided to [ __ ] him up
but now when Tilikum was doing all this
he was on valium well I can't say for
sure that that was the case I want to
suit anymore when they start putting
killer whales on valium so in in ocean
ocean areum's or aquariums and [ __ ]
valium is often used as an appetite
stimulant so when your animal is off you
know off so they don't they don't eat if
they're not responding to buckets of
food you're [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna drop
the water to get access to him because
they're not interested in more they're
not your friends anymore if you don't
have a bucket of food forget about it
and so it sort of often enough to sort
of trigger that appetite
you'll pump them with the valium -
valium if they don't want to eat stuff
it written a fault
well then you get liquid volume you can
inject as well well if Ness is I mean
that's a process the things that I've
seen and done that were normal to me and
normal to anyone who's working there is
insane we used to drop used to call this
beluga rodeo and at Marineland marina is
notorious for having like we have I say
we
over 50 experts they're pushing 60
belugas at this point this is why it's
so important to start changing these
[ __ ] laws because this is absurd and
and it creates a whole world of problems
of course socially for these animals
babies get killed by males it's it's
yeah it's gross it's bad it's not
manageable nonetheless what we would do
is we've dropped the water in one of the
pools so you have I mean anywhere
between ten and fifteen belugas flat on
their stomach there's a grate at the
bottom they can't move they can't move
well if they want to move they can but
they're flopping around but it means
they're gonna get [ __ ] up bad like
scratched up by the ground so if you've
got maybe a little bit of water we've
tried different things to try to
mitigate how damaged up they got there
was one time I mean they get carved up
we used to call it I mean it's morbid
but we used to joke around was called
the Caesar water because it was
blood-red by the time we were done those
procedures I'm telling you Joe it would
make you sick it was that the water was
thick of blood and so one time there was
a it was a beluga named peanut and she
started to panic and what she did was
she repeatedly slammed her tail in a
panic she started to bounce around like
a [ __ ] basketball she was getting air
three feet in the air she's you know
she's probably a 3,000 pound
whale two thousand pound whale or
something so you're not going to stop
that but we tried of course we jump on
her chunks of her tail I'm not joking
chunks of her tail flying off fly up if
anyone goes to marine land go ask about
peanut go take a look at her at her tail
there's nothing left of it she's got
like a nub that's sort of like you would
jagged on the bottom she was [ __ ] up
after that again lots of meds lots of
recovery but it was foul man so is this
this benzodiazepine is this a recent
thing that they started doing - no I
wouldn't say so I can't vouch for any
time before 2000 when I started but for
sure once we were there I mean so when
you go to SeaWorld
and you see those killer whales and
dolphins doing shows they're just peeled
up out of their [ __ ] minds it's a
it's hardly a assemble it's merely a
semblance of their wild counterparts
you're not going there and seeing a
dynamic animal no more you're seeing a
depressed drugged confused probably
frustrated animal and I mean again what
those what those animals go through it's
difficult for people to give a [ __ ]
about anything if it doesn't affect them
personally if you see an animal going
through this it you feel it
[Applause]